states spent at least 89 million dollars
on vaccine lotteries trying to induce
lots of americans to get an experimental
drug to go get the covid vaccine and and
they would have the opportunity to win
cash as a result of that now although
initial reports suggested that the
vaccine lotteries were successful
there's a new report out of the journal
of the american medical association that
shows that
uh absolutely none of the state
lotteries increased vaccination rates in
any way they were just a complete waste
of a lot of money
it it turns out actually that people are
not just economic animals that
are to be lured and prodded with lucr
and slop it turns out that people
actually can think for themselves and
make their own medical decisions who
would have thunk it i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from a stephen who
says that if inflation is the mark of a
good economy then zimbabwe must be the
pinnacle of civilization that's
absolutely right
but no it's good it works when your
dollar doesn't go anywhere and gas costs
75 a gallon that's the sign that there
is a lot of demand according to
the white house
you know the rising inflation the
economic turmoil the political craziness
is enough to keep you up at night but
not
if you sleep on my pillow i'm on the
road at the moment and when i'm on the
road i miss certain things i miss my
wife okay i miss my cute little baby
and
not the least thing that i miss
my my pillow my my pillow i love my my
pillow pillow my my pillow sheets my my
my pillow products they're just
great okay they are
i love my pillow because it's a good
conservative company frankly i would
shop from them if they were run by the
chinese communists that's how good the
products are right now you can get deep
discounts on my pillow mattress toppers
towels and so much more they've got a
buy one get one free offer right now on
the giza sheets they're amazing top
quality stuff they've got a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty on all my pillow products it
could be a 100-year warranty you're not
going to need it because you're going to
love those products go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners specials
for the buy one get one free offer on
the geeses sheets use promo code
dailywire at checkout or you can call
800-651-1148
get deep discounts on all my pillow
products including the pillow the
slippers the mattress topper the my
pillow telesets they've got a lot of
great stuff mypillow.com enter daily
wire or call
1-800-651-1148 tell them dailywire sent
you
1-800-651-1148 the deals won't last
forever so head on over there now do you
remember i guess it was
coming up on a year ago now that the
vaccine lotteries started to be floated
and it wasn't just the vaccine lotteries
there was something even more offensive
than telling people you know take this
experimental drug and maybe you'll win a
million dollars oh give me give me right
the thing that was even more offensive i
remember the image clearly i can't get
it out of my mind was bill de blasio the
mayor of new york holding up a shake
shack cheeseburger and just stuffing it
in his face this disgusting he says mmm
vaccination
get a vaccine and you can get a free
cheeseburger pigs he didn't call us pigs
but he was insinuating that we were pigs
um yum yum oh eat it eat your slop
bucket pig look at the french fries too
and it was so
gross physically it was gross but also
psychologically this idea that
people were making their own prudential
decision about their risk from the
coronavirus which for most people wasn't
particularly high and the
long-term data on the vaccine which did
not exist because it was a brand new
vaccine and oh but a cheeseburger oh
shoot me up captain thank you thank you
so much
no that isn't how it works and i'm not
surprised that the states wasted 89
million dollars you know when a state
only wastes 89 million that's a good day
actually compared to the other sort of
money that they just incinerate but i am
really pleased that they didn't work
because we're not just animals
we're not we're human beings we have a
rational will we actually can think
about these things and say no
no i know my i know my odds of dying
from covid i know my odds of certain
risks from the vaccines and i know my
odds of winning the lottery okay and and
none of them actually are particularly
high but this brings us to
colin powell
colin powell died yesterday he had a
very distinguished career he's been a
prominent american political figure
since the 80s since the reagan
administration he was a republican he
served in the george w bush
administration he was first black
secretary of state he
kind of
his career kind of fell apart when he
sold the iraq war to the united nations
and later came very much to regret that
decision and toward the latter part of
his career
he was
much more of a democrat and he would
vote for democrats and endorse democrats
and every time he would do that the
media would hold him out and say
lifelong republican colin powell
endorses a democrat just like he did
last time and the time before that and
the time before that so it
i know that a lot of republicans don't
have uh you know a great deal of
political admiration for colin powell
even if they have a great deal of sort
of professional admiration we're
obviously grateful for his service to
the country
my point in discussing colin powell is
not to assess his career you know he
dedicated his career to the public
service of the united states we salute
him you know we wish his family well and
can keep them in our thoughts and
prayers
the reason i bring it up is to focus on
how he died colin powell died of
complications of the coronavirus and
colin powell was
very very vaccinated
so he he took the vaccine he was fully
vaccinated but he was 84 years old and
he contracted the coronavirus and he he
died of it anyway and
this happens to people he was in a risk
group
and
that's very sad
and i just want to compare
the coverage of colin powell's death
with the coverage of herman cain's death
do you remember herman cain
herman cain was ceo of godfather pizza
he ran for president in 2012. he was a
sort of colorful figure had the 999 plan
some of you recall that and he did not
get the vaccine and he didn't
i think he may have died even before the
vaccine really came out but he didn't
worry that much about the coronavirus
and he didn't wear 17 masks and he
didn't lock himself in a bubble for a
year and a half and he went to trump
rallies and he got the virus and he died
and the media made fun of him and they
said hahaha herman cain that dumb idiot
that rube serves you right this this is
what you get when you don't live in fear
and do everything fauci says you you
play stupid games win stupid prizes you
got the coronavirus as you well deserve
that was
what they all but said uh that was the
tone of the reporting
and colin powell now followed all the
rules and took the vaccines and he he
died as well
and the reality is here
it's not that
that you die if you don't get the
vaccine or you die if you do get the
vaccine or it's directly attributable to
this this mask or this vaccine the
reality is that old people get sick and
die okay and and sometimes young people
get sick and die too and though it's
rarer and that's a reality that we used
to understand we used to be aware of our
own mortality and we used to know that
death comes for us all and no one no man
or demigod or great exalted figure even
the likes of dr fauci is going to stop
that and we used to not live in such a
neurotic fear of sickness and death and
i suspect with the decline of religion
and the rise of secularism and the rise
of the cult of health and and its
associated pathologies that now we can't
really accept that so we're always
looking for some kind of explanation and
we're always looking to spike the
football well he didn't follow the rules
so he deserved to die no we all die
frankly we all deserve to die
because of original sin and there are
certain things we can do to reduce those
risks but death is going to come for us
all and
i think that ought to give us a
healthier view of life when we come to
accept that sort of thing
but a lot of people won't do that which
is why they have a very unhealthy view
of life and it's why we're giving up our
political rights and our way of life
here in the united states but it's a
fool's errand because
it can come for us all and it will come
for us all what is harming us
is is not mortality
so much as
the obsession over health what is
harming us is the political power grab
that is represented by the the lockdowns
and by the the vaccines
you see this right now at espn allison
williams who is or rather was an espn
reporter
is leaving espn
after being denied a waiver for the
covid vaccine take a listen to her
explanation
i have been denied my request for
accommodation by espn and the walt
disney company and effective next week
i will be separated from the company a
lot of people have brought up the moral
obligation receiving the vaccine
to being a good citizen
and i weighed that and i thought about
the implications we all want to be good
neighbors we all want to end this
pandemic but ultimately an injection
that does not stop transmission and
spread for me
did not weigh in
morally but i also want people to know
who support these mandates
that i fight for you
because
if this is the direction we take our
country
there will come a time when the
government or corporations mandate you
to get something that does not align
with your values
power given is seldom returned
and when that day comes
i want you to at least know that we
fought and we tried
power given is seldom returned that's a
very powerful statement from this woman
who is actually sacrificing something
for her beliefs
beyond her beliefs about the vaccine for
her beliefs about politics and the
legitimate limits of power
okay she's losing money she's losing her
career power given is seldom returned
we've talked about on this show there
are
i think compelling arguments to get the
vaccine for some people and i think
there are compelling arguments not to
get the vaccine if you have moral
objections to the fact that they were
developed and in some cases produced
with fetal stem cells if you look at the
possibility of blood clotting or of
nerve damage or of myocarditis or
pericarditis if you have questions about
the long-term effects obviously there
are no long-term data on the vaccine
because the vaccine was just invented if
you think that your risk of covid is
very low then you might say well there's
no reason to get a vaccine at all no
particularly compelling reason okay and
that's all academic until it comes down
to the question of are you going to keep
your job
or not
and people can make prudential decisions
about that but she's taking a stand here
and i think
as she says the people who admire her
here are not just the ones who are a
little skeptical of the vaccine or
skeptical of fouchy the people who
should be admiring her here are the
people who
cherish our former american way of life
and who who want to hold the government
to account and keep the limits on power
that we had in this country until very
very
recently
you know
it's hard to see these things sometimes
in part because we have so much blue
light coming out of our screens and it's
ugly and it gives people headaches and
if you want to avoid blue light i would
strongly recommend you check out blue
blocks i no longer look at screens
if i'm going to have to see that blue
light you're probably not even aware of
it because there's so much of it in our
culture and you see it on your phone and
you see it on the tv and you see it on
the computer screen well you can fix
that right now with blue blocks okay
blue blocks they're very cool
fashionable glasses and they will
seriously reduce your eye strain i mean
i was getting headaches from my eye
strain from and you didn't even know
what it is right but then the minute you
get rid of that blue light you're gonna
see it's it's the difference is really
really stark okay for some people that
that blue light can even cause anxiety
depression low energy get rid of it now
with blue blocks they're evidence-backed
they're made under optics laboratory
conditions in australia they're really
really high-end right now head over to
blue blocks dot com slash knowles use
promo code knowles at checkout to get 20
off and enjoy free shipping on orders
over 115 bucks get your energy back
sleep better block out the unhealthy
effects of blue light with blue blocks
that is b l u
b l o x dot com slash knowles or click
the link and make sure to use code nulls
to get 20 off your order enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash knowles for
20 off today you can thank me later i
want to turn to a topic that is near and
dear to my heart
hooters you know hooters it's the
chicken place where you get wings and
beer and the women have kind of short
shorts on and tight little t-shirts and
it's
it's not the most politically correct
place and it's not the most feminist
place but it is a place where people
often go on their bachelor parties
so hooters and the reason they go is
because they have great chicken it's
like when people say i read playboy for
the for the articles you go to hooters
for the chicken wings they are actually
excellent chicken wings so hooters has
hooters has a new
uniform and the uniforms were already a
little risque and starting uh this month
all hooters girls are required to wear
these new shorts which are even
less
modest then the old shorts and they kind
of
display a little bit more in the way of
the tights and the
curves and the things that uh a lot of
people go to hooters to to see
uh so they say the old shorts should not
be worn
some women are upset about this i doubt
that really any of the hooters staff
members are upset about this
right they're working at hooters they
know what they're signing up for okay
this is not um you know some victorian
bed and breakfast or something this is a
place where you you are there to cater
to guys who want to see women wearing
skimpy little outfits
but
some people are offended on behalf of
the people who are at hooters and
they're saying this is awful and
terrible and patriarchal and sexist and
whatever
i find myself a little bit torn here
because i don't i don't think that we
ought to encourage more licentiousness
in the culture i think we've got plenty
of that and i'm not of the opinion of
the libertines you know or sometimes the
libertarians who trend a little
libertine to say yeah woohoo do whatever
you want you know fulfill any base
desires that you have just don't make me
pay for it or something like that i
think it's good to orient our public
policy toward virtue and away from vice
but i think there's a pretty
conservative argument for hooters okay
and it's it's a it's a distinction that
that increasingly in our culture the
left especially but even the right kind
of fails to understand and that is the
difference between something that is
suggestive and something that is obscene
on the grand scope of our culture
hooters is actually pretty wholesome
okay we live in a culture that is
saturated in porn so obviously there's
hardcore porn all over the internet we
live in a culture where you can barely
turn on a tv show without seeing all
sorts of crazy sex stuff and all crazy
sorts of violence and
really bizarre sorts of things you can
barely look at a billboard
i was i was in new york i was on on the
subway in new york
they've got advertisements all over the
subway car and it was for one of the
dating apps
and it's all sorts of people licking
each other and in all sorts of crazy
positions and it's a guy and a girl and
two dudes and two chicks and like a guy
and a girl and a goat and i don't know
it's all weird stuff okay and you think
compared to
that hooters is
is fine you know it's not hooters is
actually in a way kind of modest the
women are totally clothed all right and
they're not
it's not a brothel it's not a strip club
it's a it's a chicken restaurant it
reminds me of the perennial debate the
non-traversay over baby it's cold
outside you know it's a baby it's cold
outside well i really can't stay maybe
it's cold outside and the the libs
listen to the lyrics
which are of a guy inviting this woman
in to have a cup of cocoa or to have
maybe something a little stronger than
that and the woman says no no i really
can't no i really shouldn't he says no
baby come on come on it's cold out there
don't you don't want to go back out
there no i should go home no really come
on come on in right and the libs say
well this is a song about rape it's
rapey he's trying to rape her
because the libs don't understand
the difference between
rape and coercion
and seduction
right the the whole
point of maybe it's cold outside is that
the woman actually does want to stay
she's it's not that she's fleeing the
man it's like no get me out of here call
the cops right she is attracted to the
man the man is attracted to her and in
the traditional way of doing things
until about five minutes ago the man
would pursue the woman and the woman
would be modest and and resist in a way
and then
acquiesce if she liked the guy or not
acquiesce if she didn't like the guy and
now we pretend that men and women are
exactly the same and men need to take
six months of paternity leave or
whatever to chest feet or something i
don't know there's a lot of jargon now
but men and women actually are different
and
it maybe it's cold outside even though
it's a song about a guy wanting to sleep
with a girl and a girl wanting to sleep
with the guy
in a way it's sort of wholesome as well
okay there's something
perfectly normal about recognizing that
men are attracted to women women are
attracted to men and we need to
constrain those desires in a certain way
and limit them and not just have
everybody running around naked putting
all sorts of things in all sorts of
places but actually need to restrain
them even if it is just with
a skimpy hooter's hampton speaking of
triggering things if you turn to
another den of licentiousness and
obscenity yale university
the administrators of yale law school
are clamping down on free speech and
students rights
they are demanding that a student
apologize for sending a triggering email
the student is
a native american student
so on the on the hierarchy of victimhood
native americans are pretty much at the
very tippy top okay if
if
this student were i don't know also a
lesbian or also i don't if you could add
some little uh you know
accents on this victimhood but to be a
native american basically you can claim
any sort of victimhood you want and have
deference at liberal places like yale
but this student made a big error
this student is
conservative
so so that gets rid of all of his
victimhood
this student sent an email
about
the federalist society
he said we will soon be christening our
very own world-renowned nalsa trap house
nelson meaning the native american law
students association by throwing a
constitution day bash in collaboration
with the federalist society which is a
conservative law society
and the mixer would have american-themed
snacks like popeye's chicken which is
there's a very
famous popeyes chicken on yale
university's campus it's very delicious
there are sometimes shootings there but
it's great chicken all right there's a
there's kind of a fried chicken theme
going through today's show and in
addition to fried chicken apple pie and
other sorts of american snacks for the
constitution day so less than a day
after the email was sent the student was
called into a meeting with the associate
dean and the school's diversity director
and was told
to apologize to recant because not
because he's
inviting people over to the native
american house not because he's throwing
a party but because he's doing that with
those evil rotten conservatives in the
federalist society so this student i'm
pleased to say
recorded the meeting it's a very long
recording you should go check out the
whole thing because it's spooky and
orwellian take a listen to just a little
bit
it should be quite frank that like as a
man of color
you know there probably isn't as much of
a scrutiny of you as there might be a
sort of a white person in this position
and i just want to acknowledge that
there's a complexity to that too yeah i
think the um the emails association with
feds off was very triggering for
students that already feel like
that's all
it um belongs to political
affiliations that are oppressive
to certain communities uh through
policies right that of course obviously
includes
the lgbtqia community in black
communities and immigrant communities
several people said they didn't even
know if you were but they were just
concerned about the
rhetoric so i think i think what you
seen saying
make sense of like
you know look you guys don't know me
from a hole in the wall but i didn't
intend to offend anybody when i wrote
this and now you know i understand yeah
this isn't a conversation about whether
you did anything wrong it's about
language that was used that was
triggering
and you're just trying to like
take responsibility for managing through
some of the tension related to that
i just got to chill up my spine
listening to these ghouls these two the
diversity director and the dean of this
school
saying you know look thankfully oh
thankfully you're not a white guy if you
were a white guy you'd have a lot more
scrutiny you'd you'd be out
that's the insinuation
thankfully you're a person of color so
you get a free pass but
well the federalist society you can't no
that's triggering some students didn't
even know what that was but they didn't
like it they knew they didn't like it
and
by the way the federalist society is
about as milk toast as it gets okay
i guess it's conservative but barely you
know but no that's too much for yale law
school and so look it's not about you
doing anything wrong it's just that
things were said
okay
and
responsibility should be taken because
of the students and you've got to listen
i mean it goes on and on and on where
this dean and this diversity director
these ghouls say you know
might not be great in your career if
this maybe you're going to want to
apolog apologize hey we'll help you
draft the letter but hey let's do it
let's just draft a letter a little
apology yeah let's just okay and you'll
sign it and you'll sign it and you'll at
your stalin show trial you will
flagellate yourself and beg for
forgiveness and maybe we'll give it to
you but probably we won't okay
there
there is no free speech protection at
yale they talk a good game on it and
they don't cover it up and this has been
happening for over a decade now and it
really accelerated when that crazy girl
on campus screamed at her professor and
said this is not an intellectual space
this is supposed to be a place of
comfort in home for me and she cried and
whined and yelled and said all sorts of
vulgar things and it's only gotten worse
and worse since that time and it's a big
problem because yale used to be one of
the most if not the most prestigious
university in america and it has gone
the way of the culture that is to say to
take away people's rights to create a
new social hierarchy
explicitly racial and and ideological
hierarchy whereby if you are in any way
a conservative if you in any way support
the traditional american society the
constitution and apple pie you will be
targeted you will be harassed your
career could be
over even before it begins
i will be back in studio tomorrow it's
great we've just wrapped up the verdict
live tour if
you didn't catch that you can catch it
all on the yaf youtube channel or the
verdict youtube channel so be sure to go
check that out and then i'll be back in
nashville tomorrow also subscribe to the
morning wire it's a great podcast you
get it on apple spotify stitcher
wherever you listen your podcasts leave
a five star review if you like what you
hear we'll be right back with a lot more
speaking of censorship
you are very likely familiar with barry
weiss barry weiss is not a conservative
she used to work at the new york times
now she just has her own sub stack in
her own podcast and it's more credible
than anything you're seeing in the new
york times
but she's not a conservative sometimes
conservatives make this mistake where
whenever anyone questions the dominant
liberal regime in any way we just take
them in and we say you're one of us
you're one of us
but
she is uh not she's a liberal who
does not go along with the dominant
regime so
she was just on cnn she's still she's
liberal enough that she still gets
invited on cnn and she called out that
liberal ruling class for the
corruption and the coercion that it
it involves and she did this
specifically with brian stelter on the
ironically named show reliable sources
take a listen
you write there are tens of millions of
americans who aren't on the hard left or
the hard right who feel the world has
gone mad so in what ways has the world
gone mad
well you know when you have the chief
reporter on the beat of kovid for the
new york times talking about how
questioning or pursuing the question of
the lab leak is racist the world has
gone mad
when you're not able to say out loud and
in public that there are differences
between men and women the world has gone
mad you say we're not allowed we're not
able who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they
um
people let work at networks frankly like
the one i'm speaking on right now who
try and claim that you know it was it
was racist to investigate the lab league
theory it was i mean you said that
but i'm just saying that when you say
allowed i just think it's a provocative
thing you say you say you say we're not
allowed to talk about these things but
they're all over the internet i can
google them i can find them everywhere
i've heard about every story you
mentioned so i'm just suggesting of
course people are allowed to cover
whatever they want to cover
who's shutting down the conversation
who's who's not letting people spit hold
on shut up barry who's not letting keep
your mouth shut i'm not done talking
you're who's doing that you're not no
one's doing that okay i'll give you the
last word actually no i won't shut up
who's who's shutting down
uh you you are brian you are literally
shutting down the conversation right now
and
i i'm not sure that he really believes
what he's saying what he is saying is
that
the establishment media
do not in any way suppress
questions about dr fauci questions about
the
covid origins and the associated public
health tyranny that they do not in any
way suppress i don't know the
distinction between men and women and
that's just preposterous i could be
kicked off of social media for saying
that men are not women and there are
specific rules around it which we try to
get around without compromising the
truth and the reality of what we're
reporting but we've been dinged on it
before on this show at the daily wire at
elsewhere and then what is his argument
he says look
yeah maybe we don't cover any of these
things on cnn maybe we maybe the new
york times doesn't cover these things
but you can google it first of all
google will suppress the search results
but second of all is that that's really
your answer
virtually all the newspapers virtually
all the tv stations virtually all of the
main media outlets
also run by big tech which are going to
suppress certain stories like the hunter
biden laptop story or anything regarding
coved that doesn't go along with dr
fauci so that yeah the all of the power
structures are going to suppress
those sorts of views but you know if you
poke around the deep recesses of the
internet maybe you'll find something so
it's the same it's not being said what
are you talking about dude
it's really frustrating barry weiss is
totally right here and brian stelter is
demonstrating how wrong he is
but i think we need to go a little
further here
right
barry weiss is a good liberal i like her
i'm glad there are good liberals i'm
glad she's doing what she's doing she's
doing real work
we need to go further though
okay a lot of times this trap
conservatives fall into
is we pretend that good liberalism is
the goal
that you know open relatively
open-minded liberals like barry weiss
those that's it that's the gold standard
and that's what we need to aim at and
the conservatives whine about
authoritarianism where they whine about
illiberalism where they do this both
sides kind of thing and that's just not
going to cut it okay and this is why we
lose
because those words don't really mean
very much okay authoritarianism or
illiberalism go read john locke okay
john locke the father of liberalism
reads
as much more authoritarian or illiberal
or whatever slogan we want to use than
anybody who is being accused of those
things today
the the
the mealy-mouthed both sides let's just
kind of go back to five minutes ago
let's let's just preserve and conserve
the culture of
2013. that's not going to work we need
to actually have a view of what is true
and what is good and what is beautiful
and we we need to be willing to stand by
that i mean this is the point of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which thanks to you all became a
number one national bestseller i think
it became a number one national
bestseller in part because it looked at
this thing and said no the answer is not
just to repeat the same old slogans
about
keeping an open mind and
having free speech absolutism and not
telling people what to think just how to
think and you know authoritarianism or
whatever it's
liberty entails limits and we need to be
willing to set those and stand by those
things and say look
if men and women to use barry's example
if men and women really are different
then that entails certain things and
that that means that you know men can't
go into the girls bathroom and it means
that men don't have a right to dress up
like women and pretend to be women and
it means that
actually marriage has a specific meaning
and it means that no maybe the
transportation secretary shouldn't take
two or three months of paternity leave
amid a transportation crisis and it just
implies certain things and it doesn't
just imply that we can do
x y and z it implies that we can't do
certain things as well it implies
limits speaking of authoritarianism
the taliban is back in the news
because that would be quite an extreme
of authoritarianism the taliban are back
in the news because as they have now
taken power in afghanistan
some news crews are getting interviews
with them and one news news crew is
making fun of a
taliban official because they handed him
a globe and they said where is
afghanistan and this dummy
can't point to afghanistan on a map
afghanistan he's holding up the globe
they're speaking some barbaric language
i think it's known as french
and he's looking all around he just
can't
find it and they zoom in
this whole clip is going viral on tick
tock they zoom in
taliban official there is uh you know
he's struggling
and then the guy walks in and says there
it is there's afghanistan
what a dumb idiot haha that stupid
taliban guy he doesn't even know where
it is man he's so dumb
so
the taliban official
can't identify the country on the map
you know what he can do though
conquer the country and
send the most powerful nation on earth
packing within like 11 days
that's what he can do so hahaha
he can he he doesn't know how to use
maps
oh but you know what he can do conquer
the nation that we spent 20 years trying
to conquer
he he might not have a whole lot of
technical knowledge he might not have a
whole lot of book learning but he's got
a lot of practical knowledge
he knows how to
control afghanistan
he knows how to do that better than the
americans
better than the soviets
better than the british
better than a whole lot of really high
falutin fancy educated people there is a
difference between technical and
practical knowledge all right
book learning and how to really do stuff
and
the ruling class of the united states is
really obsessed with technical knowledge
and it's why now we are sending kids to
school for
many more years than we used to and were
obsessed with funding pre-k and funding
college and funding post-graduate work
and funding all sorts of things
and yet people seem to be getting dumber
right our ruling class which has so many
degrees they're so credentialed
they can't keep the supply chain running
they can't keep our money
valuable
they can't keep
the country running all that well
but they've got degrees pete put a judge
has a very impressive degrees he doesn't
know anything but he's real he's got
really really impressive credentials and
i think part of the cause of this is our
hubris
and specifically it's the hubris i don't
want both sides of this it's the hubris
of the ruling class where they say haha
those deplorable irredeemable rubes
those bitter clinging guns and bible
toting idiots ha ha they didn't even go
to princeton
yeah i bet they can do more things than
you can okay they might not know a lot
about foucault or gender theory or
something but i bet they know more about
things that actually matter and then
things that frankly are actually
true speaking of world leaders
superman
is no longer on our side i don't think
he's on the side of the taliban yet but
he doesn't seem to be on our side
superman who used to stand for truth
justice and the american way
now stands for truth
justice
and a better tomorrow
now i remember years ago 15 years ago
there was some superman movie i can't
keep track of the superhero movies but
there was a superman movie that made
waves because it replaced the motto
truth justice in the american way with
truth justice and all that other stuff
it's kind of like a joke an aside ha ha
we no longer believe in the american way
oh no we're just ironic we just we
recognize that's all a lie and we're all
we're evil americans and so we don't ah
it's just all that other stuff now
they've taken it further and they've
earnestly replaced it with
a better tomorrow
the chief creative officer and publisher
of dc comics just announced this
and everyone right now is focusing on
cultural marxism right they're saying
this is cultural marxism it's a cultural
revolution to overturn the i mean in
this case literally to overturn the
american way
and sure that's true there's an aspect
of that but i think they're missing out
on the bigger problem which is not the
marxists it's the liberals
part of the reason they're making this
change in superman
which reflects broader cultural patterns
is because they hate america and they
actually do think we're the bad guys and
they want to topple statues and tear
down the american flag and disrespect it
part of the reason though a more cynical
reason is they want to make more money
in china
okay they want to make more money in
global markets where appealing to the
american way will not get you the
highest return on your investment okay
part of the reason they're doing this is
because they have greater loyalty and
affection for the almighty dollar than
they do for the red white and blue and
for their countrymen
it's not just the commies that are the
problem it's the liberals
too and a lot of right wingers have
given into this for for many years now
a lot of right wingers have
have shield for woke multinational
corporations that hate our country and
hate our way of life and hate the
american people
and we've done we've said there is
nothing more conservative than
building a bunch of sweatshops in china
and uh
outsourcing all american manufacturing
and taking meals off american tables to
go make gizmos in in china and there's
not there's nothing more american than
selling out our traditional way of life
to try to make an extra buck in some
far-flung region of the world
no there is there is and there are more
important things in life than money
and if anyone should understand that
it's conservatives
what are we conserving
high gdp is that it that's not that's
not all i want to conserve
i want a robust economy but i want a
country too
and i want to actively discourage
our
stewards of our culture and our
corporations from undermining our
country okay and i want to use politics
to do that
because there has been a privatization
on the left and the right over the past
50 60 70 years the left has privatized
on the social issues
you know you can basically you can sleep
with whoever you want
just just don't
make me pay for it and you've got the
the right wingers who have privatized on
corporations you can sell to whoever you
want you can buy from whoever you want
and you can run your company however you
want just don't make me pay for it right
and that privatization on both sides has
led to a collapse of the american
culture we don't have social cohesion we
don't have national borders we don't
even have a flag really anymore and and
the one that we do have we sort of
disrespect right the the
libs the liberty the neoliberals the
kind of ruling establishment uses this
language of wokism
to
placate the people
and uh to put a little little patina and
a facade over their their
obvious
cynical quest for money you're seeing
this right now with the n-double or not
the naacp the ncaa the college sports
organization is suggesting they need to
eliminate the sat and act requirement so
they no longer think that student
athletes should be tested on how smart
they are and how much they know
and
the argument that they're using to
justify getting rid of this very basic
test of one's intelligence in
preparation for college
is that they need to do it to promote
racial
equity
so that's the line we need to get rid of
all these standards to promote racial
equity
so the n double a c
uh nw i keep i keep confusing these
things
it's because we're talking about race
the ncaa task force has recommended that
high school students who are looking to
play d1 or d2 sports should not have to
submit their sat or act scores as part
of the recruiting process the daily
caller is reporting
that they made these recommendations on
friday to promote racial equity
this is a prime example of
neo-liberalism using woke language to
chase the almighty dollar because first
of all what they're saying here is that
black people are dumb right that's that
is when you get past all the woke jargon
and language what the ncaa is saying is
black people are dumb and they don't do
well on tests and so if you want black
people to go to college they need to not
be tested because if they are tested
they won't get in
right i think that's offensive i don't i
don't think that's a nice thing to say i
don't think that's that is particularly
racially equitable i don't think that
promotes racial equity
but that is what the ncaa is saying
now why are they doing this
because
they
i don't think it's to promote the
education of their students i don't
think it's to promote the racial equity
among their student athletes i think
it's because they want their student
athletes to only be focused on sports
and i don't think they want their
student athletes to ever be thinking
about history or literature or math i i
bet the ncaa
doesn't want their students
pretty much ever to step foot inside a
classroom they want them to be dribbling
and shooting and and weightlifting and
practicing their sports so that the ncaa
can make more money
and because these student athletes are
not paid they're not paid anything you
know comparable to professional athletes
but they bring in a ton of money
the ncaa is going to try to ring every
penny out of them that they can but
they're not going to be able to make
that argument out in the open
they're not going to be able to say you
know dressed up like rich uncle
pennybags saying yeah let us make even
more money on these athletes yeah they
don't need to learn anything in school
what oh they're not going to have a
career afterwards who gives a damn we're
going to make some more money for those
years that they're in college no but
they're going to say no it's actually
it's it's for race just equity
diversity inclusion that's why
our students shouldn't learn anything
and
the libs are going to go along with it
the libs are going to go a lot we've
always
viewed in this country or at least the
line from the left is that the
republicans are the party of the rich
and the ruling class and the democrats
are the party of the poor and oppressed
masses no there is a ruling party in
america it's the democratic party some
republicans kind of go along with it the
squishes the court jester conservatives
but they're the junior partner in that
relationship and the democrats use the
language of wokeness
to push for the same cynical dollar
chasing ends that any ruling class or
any oligarchy might speaking of sports
going woke last wednesday ea sports
announced that they will be removing
john gruden
from their madden nfl 22 video game
so gruden you'll remember is that la or
las vegas rather
raiders coach who a dozen years ago
made some politically incorrect jokes in
his private email
and has now lost his career and is being
erased from everyone's memory before our
very eyes he's now being erased from a
video game that's already out
so the video game is already done he's
going to be released after the fact he
will be replaced this is so creepy
we are taking steps to remove him from
madden nfl 22 we will replace him with a
generic likeness via a title update in
the coming weeks
john gruden is being unpersoned in a
manner reminiscent of stalin and
evocative of george orwell and the
totalitarian ideology here
is not soviet communism and it's not
english socialism in orwell's book it is
diversity inclusion and equity
which spells die for those of you who
pay but it's diversity inclusion and
equity that's what's going on at yale
why does yale have a dean of diversity
what does that even mean because that is
that is the new chaplain
of the new seminaries okay it's the
seminaries of wokeness have a chaplain
and the chaplain is the dean of
diversity and inclusion and equity
and they are going to enforce the new
moral order and the new moral order is
radical leftism the numeral order is
wokeness okay at harvard they just
announced that they have an atheist
chaplain there and everyone was up in
arms i'm not surprised at all harvard
started as a seminary it's still a
seminary it used to promote christianity
now it churns out clerics of wokism so
of course their chaplain is an atheist
the
religion of harvard and of our country
the official religion is
secularism and atheism and it's the
ideology of diversity inclusion
and equity
and
diversity inclusion and equity it is a
jealous god okay
when
when traditional religion goes away it
doesn't leave a vacuum
what replaces religion is ideology and
that's been true for several centuries
now and we're seeing that play out
before our very eyes and a lot of
republicans don't know how to push back
against this sort of thing okay
i'm i'm thinking of the shill rep you
know the guys like asa hutchinson who's
the governor in arkansas the you know
the liz cheney types the adam kinzinger
types
they don't know how to push back against
this sort of thing
and uh actually before we go i want to
turn to the united kingdom because
there's a story that's not getting a ton
of play in america but it shows you
what's going on here
there is a conservative member of
parliament who was just killed in a
muslim terror attack his name is david
ms
i may be mispronouncing that he died on
friday he was stabbed multiple times he
was 69 years old
and he was holding a meet and greet with
his constituents he was first elected to
parliament in 1983 he's been there for a
very long time he's survived by his wife
and his five kids he was a devout
catholic and he was killed by a radical
muslim
and so the circumstances of his death
are being covered up by the pc police
but even more concerning
the man was a devout catholic when he
died
or as he was dying a priest heard about
this ran to the scene to administer last
rites this is a very important thing in
the catholic faith and the priest was
not allowed on the scene but the cops
said no sorry it's a crime scene and
you're not allowed here
the cops just didn't get it
traditionally priests are allowed to go
to these crime scenes to administer last
rites this is very important if i am
dying if it's not going to turn out well
for me
it is much more important that a priest
show up to give me last rites than that
a doctor show up or then that a cop show
up it's much more important for my soul
okay but
even though we understood this for
centuries and millennia in our culture
that has been wiped away we don't even
understand it anymore but there are more
important things in life than money
actually the the
raw pursuit of money or pleasure or the
the pleasures of the flesh
that is not the be all and end all and
actually the dominant ideology of
diversity inclusion and equity or
wokeness or call it whatever you want
that is not the true moral order okay
that does not it certainly doesn't
represent my views and it doesn't
represent reality either but we are
forgetting that we have lost our
principles in the uk in the united
states throughout the west broadly and
if if we do not hold them back if we do
not stand up for our principles right
now like that lady at espn or anyone
else some of the heroic people
that you that you see crop up every so
often if we do not stand up for them now
they will be lost and like that cop who
wouldn't let the priest come give last
rites we won't even know we won't even
remember what it is that we have lost
i'm michael knowless the michael knull
show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show as vaccine
mandates hit home police departments
begin firing cops on mass plus the new
york city council removes a statue of
thomas jefferson remember when trump
said they would do it well he was right
that's today on the bench bureau shall
give it a listen